mais mon confrère écrit depuis quelques
mois on voit une publicité de coca cola
vantant les mérites du coq
extra mais quel est donc cet extra que
l'on tente de nous vendre
c'est un extra de caféine un café
dangereuses comme n'importe quoi d'avis
quant aux excès il ya 50 % plus de
caféine que d'un coq ordinaire donc on
parle de 60 mg de caféine à 60 mg c'est
un peu moins qu un expresso déjà
présents discrètement dans de nombreuses
boissons gazeuses voici qu'on utilise la
caféine comme argument de vente
bouteille étroite bon ton sur ton
ça vient chercher le consommateur
certainement paul le le mâle type n 18
24 18 30
donc avec sont un exemple d'un produit
qui tentent d'aller chercher la femme
comme les ventes de boissons gazeuses
sont en déclin depuis quelques années
les embouteilleurs prennent d'assaut
d'autres marchés
ces produits-là extra c'est pour faire
compétition boissons énergisantes qui
les eaux sont sur le marché et prennent
le marché je sais pas d où s blc
compagnie la la rue la cei d'avoir leur
part de marché
le consommateur est friande de caféine
n'est pas nécessairement au milieu de
l'après-midi à travers un café
traditionnel j'étais morton qu'on va
chercher dans les produits comme celui
là je pense c'est ils étaient réunis
refusant et anti fatigue ou si on veut
faire des gros journée au travail ou
encore pour étudier puis est encore
encore plein d'énergie pour aller
s'entraîner par exemple des études
indiquent que la caféine peut avoir des
effets bénéfiques pour la santé mais il
peut en être tout autrement si elle
n'est pas consommer de façon modérée
si on regarde les effets à court terme
c'est lui rite habiliter les
tremblements l'anxiété les troubles de
sommeil
alors vous avez sorte de façon aiguë à
long terme
il ya des associations avec des pertes
osseuses temps des fractures dépit des
événements comme ça il ya des problèmes
hépatiques que les problèmes
d'hypertension et dans des cas plus
rares mais bien réel
les conséquences sont graves il ya des
gens qui vont malheureusement souffre et
de mort subite et d'une arythmie comme
le moule dit c'est subi
[Musique]
pour l'adulte moyen santé canada
considère que l'absorption de 400 mg de
caféine par jour et sécurité
s'accumulent en fait déjà deux cafés on
ne plus que la moitié de la dose
maximale recommandée dans une journée
avec dès qu'on va chercher une boisson
énergisante août on vient d'arriver pour
l'ex meneur pour les enfants la
consommation quotidienne ne devrait pas
excéder 2 mg et demi par kilo de poids
corporel
les enfants qui ont moins besoin de
calme pour que ce soit toxique alors les
quantités b-wing ce c'est la dose
maximum pour un enfant de 4 à 6 ans sow
pour un enfant de 7 à 9 ans puis un une
aile un enfant tête de 10 à 12 ans c'est
85 mg c'est peut-être cette cette can
est le plus c'est la moto était là avec
leurs couleurs vives
leur motif les emballages peuvent
devenir du produit attirant pour les
enfants qui pourraient être tentés d'en
boire sans en avoir la permission
ça fait des enfants qui vont avoir de la
difficulté à dormir qui vont avoir de la
difficulté à rester en place à se
concentrer qui vont peut se sentir mal
aussi le camp des vainqueurs comme ce
qui est qui palpite qui s'emballe on se
sent pas bien les enfants sont encore
plus affecté par ça
santé canada limite la quantité de
caféine ajouté dans le cas des boissons
gazeuses un contenant de 350 millilitres
ne doit pas en contenir plus de 71 mg
pour ce qui est des boissons
énergisantes un content de 250
millilitres ne doit pas en contenir plus
de 100 mg alors que la limite pour un
format de 473 millilitres et 280
milliards
il ya des gens qui en consomment 2 par
jour alors deux par jour ça commence à
être beaucoup de caféine ce c'est
quelque chose qui peut sans fil et sur
le pouce en s'en allant au jim mann
allahyar en conduisant
la consommation de ces boissons est en
constante progression au canada
c'est un marché de plus d'un milliard de
dollars par année c'est quand même assez
inquiétant parce que les jeunes veulent
effet toutes sortes de choses sans
nécessairement être conscient des effets
que ça peut avoir sur leur corps sur
leur santé on ajoute même de la caféine
à certaines zones vitamines et ça c'est
la surprise
ça c'est la grande surprise celle-ci
contient pas langue de vente celle
antioxydants grenade mais là aussi tout
d'un coup on a de l'eau vitaminée
caféine et la grande catégorie des eaux
sportive est en ascension on parle entre
4 à 10% d'augmentation par année selon
les territoires il ya beaucoup de
marketing autour du soyez efficace soyez
productif si vous êtes fatigué vous
allez vous allez diminuer votre
productivité alors il faut surtout pas
être fatigué dans la vie donc énergisé
vous avec avec du café
et que dire des nombreux autres boissons
auquel on ajoute du guarana en plus de
la caféine
de quoi renault n'est pas régulé donc
vous pouvez facilement augmenter de
grâce à ça pour ça le contenu un café
sans avoir à le dire de façon officielle
par ce que vous dites peut contenir de
guarana peu conduite deux autres
produits qui eux aussi peuvent avoir un
effet délétère sur la fonction cardiaque
est produit à créer un effet certain
parce que ça soyez rajouterai pas aux
produits de base qui est là qu'a fait m
mais on ne reconnaît pas les faits
certains ce qu'est et additifs
multiplicateur oms est bon et bien sûr
on me chercher les jeunes et là
lorsqu'on regarde comment on
on voit livré sa est bien évidemment vos
cibles et les dépanneurs à proximité des
écoles
c'est les endroits où les jeunes se
tiennent évidemment quand ça vise les
jeunes et les adolescents entre autres
qui n'ont pas nécessairement la
tolérance à la caféine qui ne se
connaissent pas non plus en termes de
consommation de caféine
on peut vite arriver un nouveau lot des
jeunes tombés carrément en commande des
cd avec seules les boissons énergisantes
devrait être régulée beaucoup plus
qu'elles sont régulés là en ce moment ça
il devrait avoir sur les étiquettes pas
une affaire cash et 10 ans peut être des
phases pour la santé faut que ça soit
d'après moi aussi fort que sur les
produits de tabor par exemple le docteur
poirier suggère même qu'on en
interdisent la vente aux moins de 16 ans
là certains pays les boissons les âmes
ne sont pas accessibles ou 16 ans et
moins est ce qu'on devrait aller là
probablement
et n'oublions pas que la caféine est
présente dans de nombreux autres
produits comme le thé et certains
desserts à base de chocolat ajoutant en
douce des quantités de ce stimulant à
notre consommation quotidienne
[Musique]